our main concept for everything is to
try to humanize my coworkers my name is
Kenji I'm messing up our documentary
photographer
if you would ask that Singaporeans do
you know about my co-workers they'll be
like yeah you know the America's near my
house building my house they don't
really know about where they come from
their lives or purge the hardship or
what they're happy about you know they
are ready familiar strangers
tell us about your life here or your
life back
we often miss out on the personal
stories instead of sharing the heavy
stuff which was very fresh and not
something that I've always been hearing
when they are having fun and making fun
of each other during the whole process
that makes me happy
when I share the stories online or
photos of them and when people say like
hey I didn't know about this those acts
of raising awareness about them that
drives me to do what I do